[Musique]
pour visiter la planète Terre,
vous devrez d'abord naître en tant qu'enfant humain,
vous devrez apprendre à utiliser
votre nouveau corps
pour bouger vos bras et vos jambes,
vous apprendrez à marcher
et à courir,
à utiliser vos mains
pour faire des sons
et  formez des mots
il y aura tant à apprendre
pour vous et tant à ressentir
tristesse
joie
déception
et émerveillement
vous allez grandir
voyager
et travailler
tu es dedans
et quand vient le temps de retourner à
ton étoile,
il peut être difficile de dire au revoir à ce
monde étrangement beau
[ __ ] ce livre
tu pleures non je ne suis pas oui
tu es définitivement merde
ta merde
[Applaudissements  ]
vous